wissen sie wer es im gegensatz zum
verbraucherschutz bei edel essen in den
koalitionsvertrag geschafft hat werwolf
meine damen und herren ja ein totales
aufregerthema obwohl in ganz deutschland
nur ungefähr 150 bis 160 erwachsene
wölfe rumrennen hier laut neuen
koalitionsvertrag wird der bund
demnächst zitat einen geeigneten
maßnahmen katalog zur entnahme von
wölfen entwickeln
dazu arbeiten wir geeignete kriterien
für die letale entnahme ja das linke
erinnert mich an filmklassiker wie spiel
mir das lied von der letalen entnahme
oder die nacht der lebenden letalen es
ist ein sehr komplexes thema und sogar
im bundestag haben sich neulich quasi
ein wolf debattiert wölfe laufen immer
öfter seelenruhig durch dörfer an
bushaltestellen vorbei an denen nur
wenigen stunden vorher kinder auf ihren
schulbus warteten ja immer mehr dörfern
18 dörfern hängen wölfe an
bushaltestellen rum und trinken
dosenbier
oder besprühen alles mit graffiti ich
will hier nichts verharmlosen aber nur
mal zum vergleich man schätzt dass in
deutschland jedes jahr 30 bis 50 tausend
menschen durch hundebisse verletzt
werden genaue zahlen gibt es
erstaunlicherweise nicht das verhindert
die hundelobby wir regen uns auf über
wölfe die stand jetzt exakt null
menschen gegessen haben alles was
kleiner und langsamer ist ist als
potenzielles jagd opfer anzusehen ja gut
das ist aber auch natürliche auslese die
so klein und langsam sind immer zuerst
die dicken essen also jetzt mal rein
biologisch gesehen für die herde die
angst vor dem wolf sitzt ganz tief drin
in unserer menschlichen dna und man muss
natürlich differenzieren das weiß sie
ausgibt wölfe und es gibt probleme würde
wir müssen auffälligen die spreche von
den auffälligen wölfen die sich den
kindern bei uns auch im waldkindergarten
in goldenstedt oder woanders immer
wieder nähern die muss warum bringen
beziehungsweise lethal entnehmen meine
damen und herren ja die auffälligen
wölfe was wäre denn auffällig nehmen wir
als beispiel wie das maskottchen vom vfl
wolfsburg das ist ja vom verhalten ja
auch unauffälliger wolf aber den kann
man doch nicht einfach da kann man doch
kann man doch meine auffällig war asche
und wirklich betroffen von der rückkehr
der wölfe sind natürlich ist jetzt kein
spaß nutztierhalter schafzüchter zum
beispiel die zahl der gerissenen
nutztiere hat sich im letzten jahr
verdoppelt sagt ja
zuschüsse für zäune wären gut oder für
herdenschutzhunde es würde helfen
und falls sie als mensch mal
überraschenden wolfs kontakt haben hier
ein paar tolle tipps
man macht sich so groß wie man kann das
macht es auch bei anderen tieren üblich
die man eigentlich bösartigkeiten planer
olaf ab
die bösartige absicht haben nicht groß
machen so forschen kann und so laut
rufen wie man kann
[Applaus]
lass uns freunde sein